le conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
c'est le grand gendarme donc de la
télévision soit que le temps de parole
d'eric zemmour dans l'immédiat soit
décompté à partir d'aujourd'hui comme
n'importe quel personnel pour les
personnalités politiques car ça pose un
énorme problème parce que ça voudrait
dire que eric zemmour il doit faire une
émission sur trois à la limite parce que
s'il est décompté tous les jours et que
son émission qui fait tous les jours et
christine kelly a trop et des comptes et
il va exploser le compteur et par les
premières à ce qu'ils aient quoi il est
considéré comme un candidat politique
c'est ça c'est ça alors c'est pour ça
regardez ce sujet de ses news et juste
après vous aurez la réaction d'eric
zemmour eric zemmour eric t-il d'être
censuré on a des jambes et sirops
secretin teddy bien sûr qu'il tenait sur
la quête mémona hintermann que j'adore
ancien membre du csa journalistes son
livre les vulnérables est disponible
partout il ya louis boyard voilà que
vous connaissez bien mais regardez ce
sujet juste après on aura la réaction
directement vous allez voir il est il et
il n'est pas hyper content c'est pas
dans son avis rendu hier le sait sa
demande de décompter les interventions
d'eric zemmour portant sur le débat
politique national pourquoi je cite au
regard des récents développements le csa
a considéré que monsieur zemmour
pourrait être regardé dorénavant tant
par ses prises de position et ses
actions que par les commentaires
auxquels elle donne eu comme un acteur
du débat politique national et la loi de
86 et prévoit la prise en compte des
interventions des personnalités
politiques et elle permet aussi et ça de
dire qu'il y en ait qui n'en est pas
alors juste avant qu on continue parce
que j'aurais à revenir sur soi la
cérémonie aux invalides vous l'avez vu
anne hidalgo aux invalides non alors
elle n'y était pas à noter pas année la
cité il la vérité pour qu'il y avait son
premier adjoint mais elle n'y est il est
malheureux gras anne hidalgo il ya bien
entendu tout ce que vous avez dit hier
soir d'ailleurs ah oui très bien
vous savez quand je veux quand je veux
tel
vous dire voilà pourquoi qu'est ce qui
vous a dit non non rien rien rien mais
je parce que c'est marrant parce que
hier c'est vrai que j'ai un petit peu
bousculé anne hidalgo
je ne ferai pas le refaire et donc et
vous avez vu vous avez croisé son
premier adjoint que vous a dit quoi non
moi je n'ai pas croisé une amie très
proche que vous connaissez bien a vu
emmanuel grégoire ce matin qui lui a dit
voilà hanouna il a été très fort hier
ouais un peu dingue voilà c'est tout
racontant enfin il est pas content mais
bon en bas il faudrait faire le boulot
alors bon goûter voilà eric zemmour
méritent ils d'être censuré merci jean
messire d'être là merci christine quel
bonheur de te voir ma chérie tu mais
vous êtes bronzés bah merci oui lundi de
nous revoir merci moitié ce qui se passe
si l'un
évoquant même un peu de talent aux deux
permanences ancien membre du csa merci
d'être là les journalistes que j'adore
et journalistes surtout surtout
journalistes d'ailleurs maintenant cette
manne oui exactement merci l'état et
louis brouillard alors eric zemmour
c'est vrai que tout le monde en a parlé
aujourd'hui eric et moi ce que c'est une
décision injuste ou est ce que pensent
et qui mérite d'être censuré eric
zemmour louis brouillard on va voir la
réaction d'eric zemmour qui les a faits
qui nous a donné sa réaction juste en
exclusivité pour touche pas à mon poste
vous verrez sa réaction dans un instant
et déjà je trouve que le mot censuré il
a pas sa place parce que on à zemmour
qui écrit un bouquin mais regardez la
une du bouquin on dirait qu'il est en
campagne il dit qu'il va aller au
contact des français qu'il réfléchit en
vérité il est en campagne est ce que
demande le csa c'est de dire écoutez
monsieur zemmour on ne sait pas trop sur
quelle position vous êtes est ce que oui
vous êtes candidat à la présidentielle
alors on décompte votre temps de parole
ou est-ce que non vous n'êtes pas
candidat et où quelqu'un on vous laisse
faire ce que vous faites ce que vous
voulez mais le problème c'est que là
aujourd'hui il ya un flou et ce n'est
pas respectueux pour les autres que les
autres candidats même les petits
candidats doivent respecter ces règles
alors la liberté d'expression tout le
monde est pourri si mais il ya des
règles particulièrement dans une
présidentielle on sait tous qu'il va y
aller et puis enfin quand on parle de
censure j'aimerais quand même rappeler
que c'est un type qui a été condamné
enfin rendu coupable trois fois d'appel
à la haine raciale et il n'est pas
censuré donc tous les jours à la télé
donc quand on passe en asie en politique
comme des signaux positifs du csa pensez
à moi ça me dérange parce que plusieurs
fois il a dérapé et d'ailleurs il a été
condamné plusieurs fois pour ses propos
sur ces news parfois il a dépassé la
limite le csa n'a jamais bougé il a
toujours été à l'antenne sur ses news
même si c'est le groupe canal je le dis
quand même plein plein de fois il a
déconné sur ses news il reste à
l'antenne là moi je pense que zemmour
est un éditorialiste et si la carte de
journaliste il est journaliste à partir
nos manques qui s'est pas déclaré à la
présidence de la république il n'est pas
candidat
c'était très con de dire ou alors c'est
une mauvaise nouvelle c'est à dire qu'il
est officiellement candidat le csa a des
infos alors si les si le csa des infos
que le csa nous dise officiellement
zemmour est candidat et on en parle bien
même si tu peux pas faire médaille ah
ouais mais tu peux pas faire tu peux pas
su pu t sur des appels à tuchan sa
réponse dans un instant sans ce virage
on n'a ni gaz vous vous êtes d'accord
avec moi je peux une fois n'est pas
coutume je suis d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit d'ailleurs le président
du csa lui-même avait planté le décor
dans un article du figaro en date du 2
juin où il disait la réponse est donc
très clair le csa ne des contrats pas le
temps de parole des chroniqueurs dans
celui des partis politiques donc là ce
soir enfin hier hier quand il a pris la
décision le ca acclamant le cs a
clairement trahi sa mission d'autant
plus que s'ils voulaient il peut y avoir
des présomptions il peut y avoir un
faisceau d indices mais le cnt va se
présenter le csa n'est pas n'est pas
gallas et à médiapart c'est pas voici le
csa doit présenter des éléments
juridiques tangible irréfragable
indiscutable qui permet effectivement de
dire qu'il est candidat à se présenter
mais ça décidé la laine et décision
d'ailleurs la connaissez vous tout
prouve la croissance elle n'avait pour
l'instant et les icônes connaissent à
savoir ce qu'il le sera il est ou pas
tout porte à croire qu'il le sera mais
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas de
preuve qui permette au cs a tranché
honteux par trancher sur des ragots ou
des présomptions voilà et puis quand à
quant à la prise de deux 2 comment
dirais-je la prise de position politique
d'eric zemmour c'est quand même un bien
piètre contrepoids par rapport aux jean
michel aphatie patrick cohen j'en passe
et léa salamé j'en passe et des
meilleurs qui à longueur de journée
distillant propagande progressistes sur
l'émission d'eric zemmour dans un
instant mais maintenant qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous vous êtes
journaliste voilà que ce soit en plus
d'être ancien membre du csa vous pensez
que c'est c'est une censure politique
pour un eczéma penser que c'est ça bien
fait de dire qu'ils veulent ils
voulaient des comptes et parce que en
voulant décompter le temps derrière eric
zemmour ils savent qu'ils vont mettre un
petit peu de côté qui va pas pouvoir
éteindre à elle tous les soirs mais eric
et moi conserve la totalité de sa
liberté de parole la totalité de la
diète sa liberté de parole en tant
qu'éditorialiste lorsqu ils n'entrent
pas de plain pied dans le débat
politique en tant que candidat potentiel
en tout cas c'est lui à vous parler de
ragots mais sont en ciel mais attendez
laissez moi
mais c'est moi juste vous expliquer mon
point de vue tout le monde dit sur la
base de ce qu annonce eric zemmour
humaine qu'il sera candidat mais il
laisse lui même planer cette hypothèse
dans le communiqué que j'ai lus du csa
hier il est bien noté qu' il y a ces
annonces qui sont faites qui laisse
supposer que mais il ya surtout une
atmosphère
un lien entre ce qui est dit et ce qui
sera fait est ce que vous trouvez normal
que deux un pays comme la france ne
serait ce que pour la liberté de chacun
qu'il y ait un seigneur qui chaque soir
puis se dérouler ce qu'il croit c'est
son idée c'est la liberté de parole elle
est garantie par l'article 1er du csa
christine kelly qui a été aussi à ça
maintenant et moi
c'est là dans la vie la liberté de
parfaire le berrigaud est conservé je
vous fais remarquer oui probablement que
en fait au figaro c'est fini pour lui
tandis qu'à la télé il pourra continuer
le mot nous attend déjà pris dans les
français que j'ai appris le mot censure
a un sens censuré ça voudrait dire un
terme hier justement et les hémois a
fait une réponse exclusivement pour tp
je voulais montrer dans un instant je
veux juste avoir d'abord le sentiment de
christine qui est en plus vous étiez au
csa vous travaillez avec eric zemmour
vraiment vous est la mieux placée pour
donner votre avis alors si vous
permettez comme je me suis occupé du
temps de parole la présidentielle au csa
je vais vous expliquer comment se passe
le décompte et quelles sont les
conséquences de la décision du csa cette
hôtesse
retrouve nos anciennes habitudes le
temps de parole et en deux temps un
tiers pour le gouvernement les ministres
les collaborateurs les deux tiers c'est
pour en marche rfi est reine les
écologistes le ps tous les autres si
comme ça a été décidé au meilleur exe
mort et on commence à le décompter il va
être décompté dans ces deux tiers du
temps de parole des partis donc
mécaniquement va diminuer le temps de
parole de rn 2 elle est fille de en
marche et va augmenter le temps de
parole de l'exécutif du président la
république de dire ce ministre de ses
collaborateurs
première conséquence
deuxième conséquence eric zemmour les
chaînes vont se dire je n'invite pas
eric zemmour parce que c'est trop
compliqué à quel moment le seul moment
dans l'histoire de la télévision où il
ya plus de débat politique ces quinze
jours avant le premier jour de la
présidentielle parce qu'on demande
l'égalité du temps de parole les chaînes
arrête tout les débats politiques parce
que c'est trop compliqué on est le seul
pays au monde à décompter aille à faire
ce temps de parole et dernier point où
aucun candidat aujourd'hui n'est des
comptes et aucun et mêlant chaussures
pour l'art et cetera cet essaim des
comptes et son départ ils sont décomptés
au sein de leur parti politique et de
l'histoire aucune personnalité n'a été
décomptés aujourd'hui aucune
personnalité des décomptes et comment on
a décalé et drôle ou pas c'est injuste
c'est pas que c'est juridiquement pour
l'instant
c'est pas tenable est ce qu'on peut et
est ce qu'elle fait mais moi je peux
comprendre moi je peux conquis la
bernoise a indiqué la ce qui peut avoir
des recours ou pas du tout bien mais on
est bien sur la la direction de la
chaîne peut faire un recours gracieux
lui il peut faire un recours c'est une
décision de calais juridiquement
attaquable donc la délibération pour la
campagne de la présidentielle n'a pas
encore été prise par le csa donc aucun
candidat aujourd'hui ne peut être
juridiquement des comptes est complet ce
soir sur ses news eric zemmour a dit
aujourd'hui je suis journaliste c'est
clair la journaliste qui se présente à
l'élection présidentielle et
du moment de faire face au taux de
france alors qu'on n'a pas fait ça vous
ne donnez enfin il faut nommer
thématique le seul à retenir les
sercices il est potentiellement candidat
qu'il va à nice à montpellier où
ailleurs dix ans
il peut garder son jeu dans sa manche
pendant très très longtemps et est ce
que est ce que c'est tenable que jour
après jour eric zemmour puisse avoir de
l'antenne à son profit et que les autres
soient à côté en train de regarder c'est
pas admissible non mais ça vous dérange
et ça c'est le cas pour l'instant
j'ai une question pour mémona hintermann
le temps parole d'eric zemmour il
devrait être décompté à partir de demain
pourquoi son allant des comptes fasse
celui de xavier bertrand ce que ces
candidats ou pressentis candidat parce
qu'ils n'aiment pas annoncer qu'on le
dit ils n'ont pas tous un blâme et avec
un énorme haut-parleurs et un tambour je
vais vous dire une chose j'ai été très
sollicités je vous préciser une chose je
dois préciser une chose le contexte est
tout cela il ya la sphère des mots et
puis le contexte j'ai été sollicité sans
cesse depuis hier soir par télé et
d'autres y compris un journal
international pour que si vous voulez
j'aille accusé le vilain bolloré
passage anti à la veille le monde visuel
christine le sait parfaitement c'est pas
les gentils contre les biens ils sont
tous des industriels ils veulent tous
avoir un segment donc aujourd'hui il ya
une chaîne qui avance qui avance qui est
ses news et puis lé voisin qui regarde
un homme en fait qu'est ce que c'est si
c'est l'occasion pour elle de donner un
bon coup de pied à cette chaîne c'est
news elles vont le faire moi j'ai pas
voulu y aller à ses interviews pour être
instrumentalisée donc ici ne me faites
pas passer pour celle qui sera là à sa
fusée mois face à pas de jets d'engins
pouvant dire qu'on n'a pas de sens
j'aimerais qu'on regarde la vidéo qu'a
fait eric zemmour pour nous c'est une
vidéo je vous dis exclusive il a fait
que pour nous il nous a préparé une
réponse pour nous dire voilà pourquoi il
trouve que c'est injuste regardez cette
vidéo elle dure trois minutes la vidéo
d'eric zemmour il n'aura il nous dit
tout bas tout ce qu'ils pensent regardez
c'est une exclusivité pour touche pas au
poste et bras bonsoir à tous bon soir
cyril hanouna c'était trop beau ma joie
aura été de courte durée hier à 16
heures on m'apprenait que la justice
m'avait relaxé dans un énième procès
politique et quelques heures plus tard
et on me disait que le csa avait décidé
de me complète de comptabiliser mon
temps de parole comme une personnalité
politique
je vous avoue que cette offensive ne m'a
pas vraiment étonné depuis des mois des
ministres du gouvernement castex des
députés en marche s'époumonait contre ma
présence à l'antenne de ces news on se
demandait vraiment ce qui les dérangeait
il paraît donc je dois être
comptabilisés mon temps de parole doit
être comptabiliser
le temps de parole de 90% je devrais
dire 99% des éditorialistes politiques
qui professent tous les mêmes idées de
gauche ne les a jamais dérangé et n'est
jamais venu à l'idée de ces éminences de
comptabiliser leur temps de parole mais
c'est ainsi moi il faut comptabiliser
mon temps de parole en vérité j'ai
toujours émis des opinions politiques
ceux qui me suivent depuis des années le
savent très bien et c'est bien mon droit
en tant que journaliste dont la carte de
presse 57 111 soutient le rappeler même
si ça ne me rajeunit pas
garanti mais droit de d'opinion
d'expression
il n'ya il n'ya absolument en a pas le
droit de censurer mes propos et le csa
en moins que tout autre moins que toute
autre institution n'a le droit de
contrôler les opinions des gens et
encore moins des journalistes d'ailleurs
le président du csa reco l'idée de metz
dans une interview qu'il avait accordée
au figaro le 27 janvier dernier avait
été très clair il avait déjà répondu à
tous les ministres qui demandait ma
comptabilisation de temps de parole
qu'il n'en était pas question qu'on ne
comptabiliserait pas le temps de parole
des éditorialistes politiques parce que
ce n'était pas l'objet de la loi de 1986
et voilà hier le président du csa a fait
mentir ses propos et a n'a pas respecté
la loi qu'il a institué voilà le csa a
montré à révéler sa partialité politique
il suffit d'ailleurs de regarder le
parcours de tous les membres du csa pour
comprendre d'où ils viennent et où ils
veulent aller
vraiment le csa n'a pas n'a pas n'a pas
respecté sa mission et d'ailleurs ça va
continuer je vous l'annoncé d' avance
déjà des journalistes militants
comptabilise mes heures de présence à
seignosse pour bien montrer que l'on ne
voit que moi comme si ces news était la
seule chaîne de tout le paysage
audiovisuel français comme si on
obligeait les français à me regarder
tous les soirs à 19h bon vous avez
compris l'objectif est le même nous
faire taire mais je ne me tairais pas
oui je me sens pas non plus fort que toi
t'es pas du tout à son sujet je suis pas
un jeu pas un fan déjà non mais là la
culture et que tu réparer en fait ce que
je réponds c'est qu'on manque le sujet
en fait c'est que il est éditorialiste
et il émet des opinions politiques et
c'est son droit et qui continue il n'y a
pas de problème mais le truc c'est qu'il
sera peut-être candidat du coup si
jamais on a un éditorialiste qui pendant
disons six mois continuent de d'émettre
des opinions politiques et qui derrière
dit au dernier moment et autres
maintenant je suis candidat ça fausse
toutes les règles en fait c'est ça le 18
mai mona mais oui c'est ça et aimée est
là aujourd'hui on dit oui mais c'est de
la censure politique alors qu'en vérité
non ça n'a rien de politique c'est juste
que bah ya des règles à respecter eric
zemmour joue avec une ligne très très
floue mais on a connu une riche de sens
et l'instrumentaliser la décision du csa
pour ensuite derrière insulté d
opérer mais qu'est ce que font les
autres les autres éditorialistes qui
sont de gauche ou qui sont du centre
mais on sait pas mes idées dit c'est pas
mes idées sauf que l'aaa à la faire
comme ça le faire taire à le faire
passer vite pour nous mais n'y a pas de
faire des signes contraires à la liberté
je voulais simplement qu'ils
jouets mattel des rentes et à faire
taire les gens comme ça vous les rendez
encore plus fort mais
prenez moi pas le faire kong a relevé
jean michel aphatie qui dit des choses
sur des plateaux télé quand vous avez
jean michel cohen qui dit des choses sur
des papes tout ça rien à voir
et n'hésite pas
quand ces gens-là donne des idées et
qu'au dernier moment il dit j'appelle au
vote de tels candidats pendant huit mois
dix mois ils ont fait de la campagne
pour ce mec là ils appellent au vote là
moi je préfère qu'ils se présentent ce
soir est volage m il est pour
le problème c'est que si celle ci est
eric zemmour avait été un candidat
gauche aux progressistes personne
n'aurait parlé bizarre mais non c'est
bien c'est même parler c'est toujours
contre les mêmes comptes hors le droit
et jamais non
c'est parce qu'il y avait un problème
quand même et général d'asi chaîne n'a
pas d'ennemi chauvinisme politiques
concourent sur angers azemmour dans une
voiture et qu'on met son clignotant pour
tourner à droite tant qu'on n'a pas
tourné on n'a pas encore commis la
fusion sel mes envies la mire son
clignotant alekna droite venait à
la wii après tant d'efforts non